it is video our eight news now i-team
showed you first and now this day care
worker will avoid jail time after
prosecutors say she broke a
two-year-old's leg the i-team the only
television crew that was in court and
our david charns is here now with what
that former worker's plea was to a judge
david and kirsten and denise is part of
a deal alicia miller avoids jail time
but must pay restitution and she also
must do community service in court she
appeared extremely remorseful for her
actions but she didn't want to talk to
us after
she made statements in court at the
sentencing with no further call you're
happy with the sentencing though in
terms of what the judge decided the
negotiation was made with the state
alicia miller's public defender speaking
on her behalf as she leaves court
a judge giving the former daycare worker
probation for mishandling a two-year-old
boy last spring breaking his leg
the eight news now i-team's vanessa
murphy first showed you this video of
the incident it happened here at creme
de la creme on durango near sahara in
the southwest valley we don't see what
unfolds behind that piece of furniture
but we do see the other children's
reactions
as part of a deal miller agreed to a
charge of attempted child abuse
psychologically
was a feral empty shell
the child's mother who asked not to be
identified said this was not an attempt
it happened
he would pull his blanket over his head
to hide from people and whine and cry if
they came near him
even if he knew them the parents are
also suing the daycare center for
negligence and abuse
they say their son has ptsd and that the
incident affected him both physically
and mentally i want my son back
i want our lives back but most of all i
do not want ms miller to ever have the
chance to hurt another child
a judge giving miller probation and if
she completes her probation without any
other issues her charge will then be
reduced to a gross misdemeanor she told
the judge she now has two jobs neither
involved working with children i'm david
charns live local now